all right everybody welcome to another
YouTube hangar super excited to be here
this is part two so I recently did an
interview with Erica from Matthew juicy
and she wanted to ask me about my top
ten rules for success for millennial
entrepreneurs who are starting off part
time had it built a full time business
and we got cut off my internet shut down
after seven rules so Erica welcome back
let's do this again yes so what what we
just talked quickly before we went live
that I would recap with the first seven
that we got through and then introduced
three more so that that she had it she
can do her full ten for her audience
luckily I wrote down the first seven cuz
otherwise normally for me is it uh and
so we did this in collaboration with my
live audience and what we came up with
the first seven was number one follow
your passion and this was mine this is
one that I always believed on trees to
follow follow your passion a lot of
people do business just trying to make a
lot of money and you see people on TV
make a lot of money like wow that's
that's what I want to do but the way to
get there is that you have to do
something that you love and the people
who chase ideas just to make money never
make it but the people who truly loved
the work like you love what you're doing
that's that's that's a secret to getting
through number two is having an
environment for greatness and so you
know you look behind me and you see you
know these great people that inspire me
I'm a daily basis when I walk into my
office and you know you may not have you
look at the millennial entrepreneurs
they may not have a lot of greatness
from they have friends who are putting
them down or family don't believe in
entrepreneurial ventures you need to
start filling your head with resources
with knowledge is information that
helped you become that great person
because if you don't then you're going
to you're going to look like your
parents are going to look like your
friends right you're the product of the
five closest people around you and so
you know it may mean switching your
friends a little bit but it could also
mean just you know instead of playing
pokemon go start watching
interviews from successful entrepreneur
start reading more books you know start
in your downtime doing things that help
you be that best version of yourself and
so having down on a consistent basis can
help you get to where you need to go
number three what does it's not about
the resources about the resourcefulness
a lot of entrepreneurs when they're
starting up especially complain well I
don't have the money to do that you know
I didn't I auto the right education my
parents aren't rich you know I didn't go
to the right school whatever the excuse
is and if you look at some of the most
successful entrepreneurs and people who
you look up to where was on your list of
your favorite entrepreneur in the world
chances are they started with less than
what you have already right now and the
most successful entrepreneurs aren't the
ones who start off with a ton of money
it's the ones who find a way to make the
one doll that they do have stretch
thousand different ways and investor
hustle and energy and ideas and
creativity in the building something up
and so stop stop blaming lack of
resources because resources is not the
thing that's holding you back you need
to be resourceful number four is making
monies go providing value and so if you
want to make money if x value and make
money quickly have to provide value
quickly it's one of the fundamental
rules of business probably you know the
most fundamental want to guess whatever
business you're looking at starting look
at how you can contribute to somebody
else's life how you can alleviate a
problem for them how you can provide
value to them the more you can do that
the more that they recognize and
appreciate that value the more they're
going to be willing to pay you for
whatever you're doing and so instead of
just looking at how can I make a lot of
money look at how can I help somebody in
a really significant way and if they
really appreciate that then that's your
step to starting to make money number
five with smallest issue with the head
big ones with the heart when your head
in your heart or a line it's easy that's
that's the path that you want to go down
the struggle becomes when the logical
safe practical thing to do is on one
side and then the risky you know not so
certain path but that you really feel
like you want to follow
is the other way and the challenge is
your head can only think of a world that
currently exists where your heart you
can create a world that doesn't yet
exist and so just making a list of pros
and cons it's not the way to make the
big decisions in life you have to trust
your heart and what you feel most
passionate excited about just like if
you're thinking about you know marrying
somebody you don't just make a list and
then decide based on that list okay they
have more pros and cons I'm going to
marry that person then we have a ton of
cons but there's something there that
just attracts you to them and makes you
a better person and so you have to go
and test it a little bit more and so
quite often your head in your heart or
not aligned and the big decisions you
want to meet with the heart and the
smaller ones like okay I've made that
decision now how do I do it what are the
practical steps are going to accomplish
it those are the ones you make with your
head number six let's build around your
values and so the thing that helps
separate you from everybody else is that
you know you're a unique person you have
a set of values that are different
people will buy from you because they
like what you stand for as a human being
and you have to draw the line somewhere
as to what your business will or will
not do and usually you know the devil
comes with a bag of gold you know that
there's an opportunity to do something
that will pay a lot of money but you
don't quite feel comfortable with what
do you do and that's where you want to
stay true to your values the values and
also become good marketing for you you
know if you look at Whole Foods you
assume that it's healthy so people want
to go in the whole foods and they're not
checking the labels anymore when they go
in because it's healthy foods when you
wine from the honest company it's
honestly produced so you're not as
worried about and people will pay more
when they know the business is based on
a real set of value so understanding
what your business is all about what
your poor values are as a human being
and then bringing that to your business
will help you make important decisions
and also bring on the right customers
for you the right employees for you as
you continue building this is like a
part-time thing to start but
you want to have an eye towards the
future for something bigger and the
number seven where we ended was that the
suggestion was taken more showers and I
converted that to allow for creativity
we're really uh a lot of times we're so
caught up in the day-to-day in the grind
in the just especially someone who's
doing a part time they're in school they
have part-time job they're all stressed
out their business on the side the doing
a million things at once when you're so
busy and structured it can also mean
that you don't come up with anything new
exciting creative and different and so
you need to make sure that you allow
time for creativity I get you know a lot
of my best ideas in the showers or on
vacation or while camping or taking long
drives right so making sure that you
have that time because often your best
ideas that's when they're going to come
when you're doing something relatively
relaxing but also kind of active so like
you're in a shower you know you're
you're relaxing at the warm water but
you're also you know moving a little bit
so don't planning your life so it's so
structured that you don't have love you
don't allow yourself the time for
creativity so those were the seven that
we started with a quick recap for those
who uh who you know may have not have
seen the first one now I'll add three
more looking around at the ten number
eight would be for me don't spend money
until you're making it a lot of people
feel like you have to make money to you
have to spend money to make money and
that can be further from the truth where
I hate spending money until I'm making
money you know like especially as a
student in so many part-time doesn't
have a lot of money to then go and say
well I want to start a t-shirt company
and in order to get the price discounts
i need i need to buy 5,000 t-shirts and
it's going to cost me ten bucks assured
and that's 50 grand then maybe you
borrow that from your parents or you
know take out a huge loan or you know
whatever it is like that is not the best
way to build a business because a lot of
people then buy those 5,000 shirts and
then it sits in their mom's basement
because they've sold three of them and
the rest are just sitting there losing
money where it's much better to invest
your heart
your house of energy into finding a way
to add value to start making money
before you start spending so he's an
even an example like I still do this
today when I started my youtube channel
I already had a successful business and
I wanted to get into YouTube and I did
go out and buy the gear and the lights
and the microphone in the camera and the
tripod and the green screen and all that
stuff because I didn't know if I would
stick with it because they know if it
would work and a lot of people do that
if you i am going to be a youtuber and
Zekk okay to do this I need to get the
newest camera and tripod and all this
stuff and suddenly there eight thousand
dollars in the hole and you do two
videos is it guy you know I don't really
like this and you're stuck with all this
gear that you can maybe sell but the
auto reduced price and so I'd much
rather bootstrap my way find a way to
make it work find a way to add value and
then invest money back into the business
as I'm growing so whatever your big idea
is find a small way to get started find
a way to put something out there that
doesn't have to cost you money that you
can use like if you're doing t-shirts
you don't have to go and print t-shirts
yourself and use a print on demand
service where they print them one by one
for you and yes you lose like you'll
lose profit compared to doing it but
doing yourself and bind 5,000 t-shirts
but it helps you build momentum it helps
bring some money in and there's no risk
for you of money going out at the start
and you're making the wrong bet and when
when you start getting some results then
you can ramp it up you can you know if
you're making that t-shirt as an example
and you're making only two dolls a shirt
because you're using some third party
service when you see that it's working
you're building an audience up and you
know what kind of designs are working
you're making some money then you could
invest that into making your own line
and bringing it in house but find the
smallest way to get started and a lot of
people use that as a reason for not
getting started off as if you they don't
have the money to get started the money
won't save you you've got a you've got
to get started invest your hustle time
and energy because what I hate seeing is
people go out and taking a huge loan and
you know they're in debt for the rest of
their lives because they made the wrong
decision at the start or they or oh my
the parents and they can never pay it
back and is this constant fight because
you know they took this huge bet so make
smaller bats and make them more
consistent okay makes sense um number
nine evolve your business with you so
especially carving your younger years
there's a lot of there's a lot of
changes that happen there's a lot of you
know as you grow when you learn and you
take on new experiences and you travel
you change the human being and where a
lot of entrepreneurs get stock is they
start a business and they may get some
results to make it a little bit of
success but then they find that they
grow tired of the business they're not
anymore it's back to the first one to
following your passion like did you
start it for the right reasons in the
first place you'll number one but also x
times people will will just lose
interest in their business they're
tighter than the same thing day in and
day out and day in and day out and they
started their business to not have to go
get a job to not have to work for the
main to not have to be in a huge
corporate job and what they've done is
now built themselves a job that they
don't like going to and they hate and so
what can make you successful in the
early days can be the anchor that
prevents you from moving forward because
you're doing the same thing over and
over and over again you grow bored of it
so the key to success there is as you
change and evolve and grow as a human
being you need to bring that to your
business your business should always be
a reflection of what you are interested
in and so you want to always bring you
new creative ideas you want to always be
testing out new things if you look at my
youtube channel the videos that i
started with and not the same videos
that i have up now on my channel you
know my interests have changed what i
want to do is change and so I brought
that to my business constantly
experimenting and that brings me
satisfaction and joy where a lot of
people lose interest after six months or
a year or two years because they've
stopped injecting new things they
haven't evolved their business as it
evolved as a human being and then number
ten the last one for me is modeling
success where this is what really saved
my company nearly years was 19 years old
had my first business I was struggling
those becca three hundred dollars a
month you know not
would survive and uh I thought I had to
come up with every idea myself and what
I realized was I'm not the first guy to
try to do this before and I looked at
Bill Gates and how he started his
business microsoft and how we went from
zero to one I don't care how Bill Gates
makes an extra million or billion
dollars now like zero to one that's what
I wanted to do how can I learn from that
and through him was with partnerships he
found partnerships to ally with himself
with and helped him build Microsoft up
and that helped save my business I
formed my first partnership I brought in
13 half thousand dollars which doesn't
sound like a lot of money but to me that
was like jackpot and I've used that
strategy ever since where I almost quit
that business where I told my business
partner that I quit that like I'm tired
of not getting any results I'm tired of
feeling like I'm not contributing value
here I'm out I went from that moment to
finding finally a way through i was just
a whole bunch of pent up frustration
without without getting any results and
so understanding that whatever your goal
is whatever you want to accomplish
somebody's already done it somebody has
already done what you want to do mean
I've done exactly the same way you want
to do it but there's lessons that you
can learn of the people who have gone
before you and so I would look at two
things one people who you look up to in
your industry so if you want to be you
know a clothing entrepreneur go look at
people who started clothing lines and
see what they've done how did they get
started look at calvin klein look at
Russell Simmons look at the people
who've done and look at Vera Wang right
all these people have done it already
they may not be exactly what you want to
do if you want to do you know urban
street where you can still learn from
Vera Wang and how she started her
business the second part is though it
also look at these are aspirational
mentors I look at people who are not in
your industry people who just look up to
just people who you're a fan of you know
maybe want to be a clothing entrepreneur
but you love Oprah Winfrey like Oprah
Winfrey her message her story just you
love her right well how did she get
started learn from her success like just
because you
in a different business it doesn't mean
that you can't learn from somebody else
so now I can learn from all these people
nobody's in the business here that I'm
in but I've learned from them and
applied it to my company and so modeling
success and probably the biggest mistake
I made as a young entrepreneur was
trying to figure out everything myself
where when I flipped a switch and
realized I'm not the first guy to try to
sell soft before this stuff has already
been done I just need to study their
stories study the clues and apply it to
my business with a little kind of tweak
that's when I start to see success so
that's it those are my 10 not really as
well as well I do have one question
though what is the most common mistakes
that should see a young entrepreneur do
when they sign a business part-time uh I
think is a combination of a lot of these
rules just like the opposite right like
don't they're not following their
passion um maybe one that that i would
add that's not in the top 10 here would
be just patience it just takes longer
than you think it's going to take like
it's a grind it's a hustle it takes it
takes a long time so if you're making a
business plan you know you have your
best case in worst case scenario it's
always worse than your worst case
scenario it just takes longer and this
was a real struggle for me because
anything i applied myself to when i was
in school i would do well at right if i
apply myself to my studies I would get
good grades if I applied myself to
athletics i would i would run faster i
would score more buckets you know when i
put in the work i would do I would get
pretty quick results with
entrepreneurship I was hustling i was
working every day i was showing up at my
business partners condo i was working
from his dining room table because as
you know home office was too small every
day I would show up and I would just
like eat live breathe this business and
it wasn't getting results and I don't
think people talk enough about how hard
it is to get going and people don't
share about the pain and suffering that
they go through because then you look
online about the neck
youtube entrepreneur millionaire or
young super success star and and you
think men why why like everybody's
having on success why am I the only ones
sucking where most people suck at the
start that's part of the game so giving
yourself uh you know permission to Sakai
gas and understanding is going to take
time to build up having a little more
patience and that's why the passion is
so important like tying back in the rule
number one because if you're only
attached to the outcome you won't
achieve success you have to enjoy the
process like the grind the hustle the
work has to be something that you enjoy
doing because if you don't you just
you're gonna quit it's just too hard so
that hard work that other people look at
and say that's insane i'm never going to
do that you would do it because you
don't see it as crazy work you enjoy
that process you know I've made three
thousand videos plus on my youtube
channel not only more public but three
thousand videos like that's a lot of
work but I love making YouTube videos
right like this right here we're making
other video this doesn't feel like work
for me I enjoy it I enjoy this process
and so that's what you need to find the
thing that you would do even if you
weren't getting paid for it because
you're not going to get paid for for a
long time you got to have the patience
that keep going through and I think a
lot of entrepreneurs just quit too early
like they start it up and six months
later hasn't gotten them any money so
like okay I'm at you know that didn't
work it's not that it didn't work you
just didn't give it enough time or
invest enough heart and hustle into it
to make it work hey it's a great party
because I should say and nowadays reham
the society settles a dream that it's
from one date or not to the next one you
become a success so it's great that
you're saying that because none of
people knows about that how long it
takes to become successful yes yeah and
there's no like and I get that I get
asked that a lot to like how long does
it take there's no rule this is no like
hey after two years will be successful
but even like if that's if you're asking
that question then you might be in the
wrong business right like if you're
asking that question like oh
okay one year I'll be successful and if
you don't hit that mark then you're
going to quit then you're probably in
the wrong business a certain way but if
you want to be a singer and you haven't
made it after a year do you love singing
like if it's inside you and stuff that
you have to do then you have to keep
going you just find the way to keep
going if it takes you 10 years or 20
years to get going and so don't have an
end line it's just constant work it's
it's work that you love doing and that's
a consistent message like look across
successful entrepreneurs successful
musician successful innovators
successful politicians you know in any
industry the people at the top of their
field they love what they did and it
just kept going through it even if they
weren't having initial success uh-huh
that this Rishi Cup TV in the live
viewers bringing up first which is a
good point Matt juicy so madly juices so
she's like we have to say but also just
talking about service-based businesses
being easier to bring cash flow than
products which I always recommend it to
start to and it's good for millennial
entrepreneurs just getting started off
it's way easier to bring in money and
make money doing a service then selling
a product a lot of times your product
doesn't hit a lot of time your product
costs a lot of money to get going or if
you consider service you just you're
treating your time for money it's harder
to scale it's harder to build something
much bigger based off a service but it
gets you close to a customer and brings
in cash flow faster so ideal you can
sort a service-based business and then
transition to a product what you have
actual coming in and you're close to
your customers okay excellence I feel
that one one of the things that can be
hard for millions is pricing but I know
we already talked about it but it's just
you know at the beginning when you
launch in your business some are afraid
to put the right purse you know pricing
that would help them leave basically you
know
so like folks for services like that
when you you gnashing a business well
would be a recommendation sure and
pricing is not just an issue for
millennial entrepreneurs it's for all
entrepreneurs um I think in general
entrepreneurs underpriced themselves
they don't get the price that they want
because they don't believe that they
deserve that price I am absolutely end
up on the pricing themselves too much
this number ways to do it you know for
just research point of view you can look
at what you can put it as a charging
just to get a sense of what's going on
in the market I hate basing up my
pricing based off what my competitors
doing though but just so you have kind
of a baseline for what's going on
there's standard like cost plus so cost
me this much i'm going to charge you
know fifty percent margin i'm going to
get to this price but really the best
the best way to price your product
service is based off of the value that
you can provide to them and sometimes
it's hard to judge and sometimes you
need to get out there and just start
playing with your pricing and seeing
what kind of feedback you get you know
when i started doing videos with
sponsors for an example like brain sort
of wanting to do deals with me the first
brains would pay me five hundred dollars
to do one thing with them about 500
bucks that's great you know i probably
done it for free just yeah just to put
that brand on my website hero um so but
they can be hundred bucks right and then
what sort of happened was you know they
came back he wasn't more and I tried to
provide way more value to write like
they just wanted me at that time they
want me to write a blog post for the
article wasn't even video yet write a
blog post for the article 300 words and
they hired 10 people to do that
assignment and I didn't just write 300
words i wrote 1500 words animated video
and i promoted it to my newsletter list
and i sent people i was engaging in the
comments and so my post did better than
the other nine combined and so when they
were making decision as to who they want
to bring on they picked me over
everybody else because I provided the
most value to them and then I started
increasing the pricing right it went
from 500
I was in the 1500 and then with that
client it stopped the 1500 that you know
they couldn't afford it anymore and I
moved to other clients were like 2000
2500 and so a lot of pricing is
experimentation and seeing who can
afford your services at the start though
you got to make sure you can provide
that value right at the start you gotta
you gotta test up the waters and see
like pitch somebody I don't know what
they're selling you're selling t-shirts
okay tell you shiver 30 bucks in see if
you can get somebody to see people like
it they appreciated for what it is is
there enough quality in it right are you
buying some high-end you know fabric
that's your sewing into it or is it some
you know super cheap fabric that people
you know that breaks down and somebody
puts it in the wash right and people to
communicate that value to others but I
think in general entrepreneurs
underpriced themselves for the right
that they do provide most because they
don't believe that they're providing
real value when they are we just start
don't have the confidence yeah and
especially young entrepreneurs you're
first getting started so if you're
you're putting your product/service out
there you're getting some results try it
like the next call you get this is how
it is right like when a brain comes to
me and they say hey how much is a
costume of this twenty one hundred
dollars and like okay great okay next
time it's 3,000 right or 4,000 right on
a feudal da 2900 you like you got to
figure out what your ceiling is where
the cash is for for the product that
you're selling okay I think it's a much
better way to go than just trying to do
a fixed like okay here's our expenses so
we're gonna add percent margin and
that's what the prices all right I love
it well we're on time we got through it
all and half an hour it's awesome one of
those sup Erica for everybody watching
on my channel what's the best way to
reach out and follow you and learn more
about what you're doing alright so you
can go on ww that my did you see that
calm and for Twitter its managers he
also at my teachers
find us there pretty myself I love it
well thank you erika for the time taking
guys for watching you're trying to
believe have a great rest of the week
see you soon I'm at